>> Well, good afternoon
everybody, thanks for coming today
I appreciate it. I appreciate
everyone's patience today.
One of the things
I wanted to mention
that really resonated with
me was the following quote,
"Failure from small mistakes to
huge miscalculations is
a necessary and critical part
of our children's development."
These words really
resonated well with me at
the time when I first read them,
because it was also
about the time we were
going through our own growth
mindset effort here
at the company,
and I was dealing with
the terrible teens
and my own kids at home.
And so trying to be
able to figure out
when should I let
my son miss the bus,
how many times should
I let him miss the bus,
and then what do we
need to do to really
make sure that he's
going to grow up to be
a successful child and
a successful adult.
Our speakers today, her book
really helped me and
my wife in this effort.
I'd like to welcome
educator, writer,
and speaker,
Jessica Lahey today.
As an English writer,
English and writing teacher,
a columnist for
the New York Times,
and corresponded
with The Atlantic,
which I have a subscription,
I recommend you
all should as well.
She's also author of
the best-selling book,
The Gift of Failure.
How the best parents learn
and let go so their
children can succeed.
I'm hopeful that I can
be one of those parents
in some lifetime at this point,
but I'd like to introduce Jess,
and welcome here
at Microsoft today.
>> Thank you so much.
Thank you so so much
for coming today,
I understand there's
competing talks today,
so I really really appreciate
the attendance and
today I'm going to be
getting into some of the details
of sort of how I ended
up here and my work,
but one of the things you
should keep in mind is that
my son Finnegan, if
you've read my book,
my son Fin is sort of
a centerpiece of the book,
and he is here today.
So and he's happy to answer
questions occasionally.
So he's also acting
as my assistant today.
So anyway why I'm here,
so I have been
a teacher for 20 years,
I've taught every grade
from six to 12th grade,
I was a Latin and English
and writing teacher,
and currently I'm
an English teacher in
an in-patient drug and alcohol
rehab for kids in Vermont.
So my work is actually heading
more in the direction
of addiction prevention.
That's what
my next book is about,
preventing addiction
in adolescence
by starting when
they're very very small,
and so that's what
I'm really excited,
to sort of segue into
those conversations.
But what this book
really has been about for
me is so after
20 years of teaching,
I think when I first started,
and by the way I never
intended to be a teacher.
I thought I was going to
be a juvenile attorney.
I went to law school and studied
Education law and Juvenile law,
I was going to work
in Juvenile court,
and then I was asked
to go teach a class,
and I came home that first day
and my husband took
one look at me and he
said "Are you even going
to finish law school?"
Because it was so
obvious that I was
completely sunk as a teacher,
as that was what
I was going to be,
and that's what I've
been ever since.
So I finished law school but I
went straight into teaching,
and have been doing that
my entire adult career.
And most of my career actually,
my heart lies with
middle school.
Because middle school was
this incredible place where
my job is to watch kids
screw up all day long,
and I get to especially where
I've most recently
taught middle school,
it was really really small,
our school area, our classrooms
and our locker room,
so my office was sort
of right outside one
of the locker rooms,
and so I would hear
these kids out there talking,
and I would go out there
and mill about with them,
and I'd say something
like "So sweetie,
today is the sixth day
you've forgotten everything.
So what are you going to
do, what are we going to do,
how can I help you come up
with a strategy for day seven,
what's your plan for day seven?"
And we get to talking about
some possible ways to
use this plan book,
how he's using it now,
if he's even using
his plan book by the way,
what we can do differently,
maybe for day seven.
And what started to happen
more and more often,
was we get into
this great learning
opportunity and he was
listening and I was helping him
through the things he tried
and things that hadn't worked,
and let's try this instead,
and then all of a sudden
about 10 years ago,
what started to happen was
the door would open and
the parent would run
through the door with
like "Here's your
homework, here it is."
And the kid would say
"Well, that's my strategy,
I mean why do I need to come up
with anything else
because all I have
to do is text my parents
and they'll bring
it to me at school".
And from my perspective
that was frustrating.
And that sort of
was the beginning of
what I also started to notice
as a real divide between
teachers and parents.
When I first started
teaching I sort of thought,
"It's going to be beautiful,
it's going to be me,
and the parents, and the kids,
and it's going to be
all about the education,
and we'll braid
each other's hair,
and talk about the learning."
And that's not where
we are right now,
especially in really high
anxiety, high pressure schools.
Increasingly we have
this adversarial relationship
between parents and teachers,
which as a teacher
that just doesn't work,
because there's plenty
of research to show
that the better the relationship
between home and school,
the more productive
the kid can be,
the better informed
the parents feel,
and the better the kid does.
So, creating a schism between
home and school benefits no one.
And so then I was
concerned about that,
and then I became acquainted
with Dan Pink's work.
Obviously it's out there
in terms of his TedTalk,
and his book Drive,
and knew that a lot
of the things we were
doing to get kids to engage,
whether that's behaviorally
or with their schoolwork,
things like sticker charts,
and things like money for
grades and stuff like that,
I knew from reading
Dan Pink's work and the work of
someone else that I'll
talk about in a minute,
that that doesn't work.
That it feels like it works
because it works
in the short-term,
but over the long-term we
undermine kids
motivation to learn.
So that sort of
really well-trod territory
and I'll go into
the research in a second,
but what was even
more concerning was
that I was starting to
feel, and I wasn't sure,
this is pre-writing the book
and doing all the research,
that not only were we
undermining kids motivation,
we were undermining
their actual ability to learn.
That when we intervene,
when we run through the door
with their homework,
when we offer money for grades,
when we use sticker
charts for kids,
when we rely on the grade
itself as the reward
as I'll get into,
that what we actually
do is make it so that
our kids are less able to learn,
they are less teachable,
and that was devastating.
I had a student who
wrote a paper for me
explaining that
her obsession with being
perfect had made
her so obsessed with
her grades and her scores
and looking good in front of me,
and looking good in front
of her classmates that
she had lost
interest in learning.
It was no longer
about that for her.
She was so obsessed with
the points and the grades
that learning was
now as she said,
beside the point which
again devastating for me,
because I taught
her for three years.
I was her advisor,
and at the time,
hold your hats here,
because at the time
I was teaching
Latin and English and writing.
Sixth grade, Latin.
Seventh grade,
Latin. Eighth grade, Latin.
Seventh grade, writing.
Eighth grade, writing.
Seventh grade, English,
and eighth grade English,
all at the same time
and I was her advisor.
So there were days
where I had her for
three classes and
an advisory period,
so I knew her really well.
And this is a girl
who had come into
my classroom in sixth grade
just so excited to
learn, she couldn't wait.
"Mrs. Lahey, Mrs. Lahey,
what are we going
to learn today?"
And now she's telling me in
eighth grade that she no
longer cares about learning.
So, somewhere along
the way we screwed her up,
we did that to her.
Between and first of course,
from my very high horse
as a teacher,
I was like "Her parents
have done that to her,
it's not me, I'm fantastic.
But her parents are screwing
up my ability to teach her
in the way this is me and
my noble profession and
education and learning,
and they, you people are
screwing it up for me."
Unfortunately, then I had
these children of my own,
I have one who's a freshman
in college right now,
and Finnegan, Fin who
is in eighth grade,
thank you I saw that look,
and at the time I realized
as angry as I wanted to be
at you people for
screwing this up for me,
I was doing the exact same thing
to my own children.
Fin, believe me,
there are lots and
lots of stories that
I'm not allowed to tell,
but the authorized ones
I am allowed to tell,
and one of the authorized
stories is about
the day I found out
that when he was nine,
that Fin didn't know how
to tie his own shoes.
I found out because he hadn't
been attending PE class
because he had been wearing
his brothers boots to school,
which wouldn't be that big
of a deal except for the fact
that his brother is
five years older than him,
so they weren't
really boots so much,
as they were like leg casts
because they went over,
and he couldn't bend his knee.
And so he couldn't do
PE and so he came on
the same day actually
that I got that essay from
the student about the fact that
she no longer cared
about learning.
I was trying to
get to the bottom
of this sneaker situation,
where are the
sneakers, why aren't
you wearing the
sneakers to school,
and I came to find out that
the only sneakers he had access
to were his sneakers with laces,
and he wouldn't wear
those because he
didn't know how to
tie them and he had
been too ashamed to tell me,
and he'd been too ashamed
to tell anyone else,
and so I had to come to terms
with the fact that
I had done that.
Your kid is little,
and they first get
manual dexterity and tying
shoes is hard so
you sit down you think
"This is going to be great."
Totally Instagram worthy right?
You're going to work on
the shoes and he's
going to learn how to
tie his shoes and everyone's
going to be so proud,
except it's really stressful,
and it's really hard,
some kids get manual dexterity
later than others,
and getting the laces just
right is really really hard.
And so that first day I
didn't want to see him
frustrated so I did it for
him. But just that one time.
Except the next day we were in
a rush and it's faster if
I do it and so I did it that
day but just that one time.
And now, I'm in a situation when
I first started looking
at writing this book,
he's nine and he's so humiliated
about the fact that he
can't tie his own shoes
that he's just
avoiding it by wearing
boots all the time.
So that's where I was.
As pissed off as I
wanted to be at you people,
I had to realize
I am you people.
So, off the high horse,
I came and I started
researching how these
extrinsic motivators,
motivators that come from
outside of us like grades and
points and scores and money
and rewards and
all that kind of stuff,
how that undermines
motivation and how
that undermines
their ability to learn.
And luckily, I'm also
an education journalist and
so I was writing for the
Atlantic and the New York Times,
I published an article
at the Atlantic
on a research study
that was looking at how
over parenting kids affects
their trajectory in school
and that sort of started
this whole deep dive for me.
Okay, so let's start
at the beginning.
Dan Pink, TedTalk, Drive based
a lot of his work on
another book by Edward Deci.
And by the way, if you go
to jessicalahey.com
under speaking,
there's a big button that says
download speaking
bibliography and
it has every book
I'm going to mention,
every YouTube video, every
resource that I might even
touch on is all there.
So just jessicalahe.com
big button downloads speaking
bibliography under
speaking. Okay, Dan Pink.
So Dan Pink based
a lot of his work,
the early work on Edward Deci,
Why We do What we do,
The Science of Self-motivation.
Edward Deci found along
the way what we have come
to realize is there's
40 years of
really great research
on the effects of
extrinsic motivators.
Not only 40 years
of really good research,
there's metadata,
there's studies of
that 40 years of
research to show
one really clear thing,
that when we lure people
when we give people
extrinsic motivators in
order to get them to learn,
we undermine their
interest in learning.
From my perspective
as a teacher,
it means if you
want your child to
not want to learn math over
the long-term
the fastest best way to
sort of kill that off is
to pay them for
their math grades.
What's really interesting
about this research
though is there's
also research showing
that when we offer
extrinsic motivators to
get kids to do stuff,
we also mess with
their creativity.
So, that's a problem
because as a teacher,
from my perspective,
education should be
a long-term creative endeavor
and if we're screwing
around with it,
from my perspective as with
grades I mean those
are the tools I
have and then from
the home perspective with
money for grades and that
kind of thing, we're
in big trouble.
The creativity stuff is
really interesting when you
try to control an artist's
output or offer them rewards,
offer them trophies or
money or whatever
for their output,
it turns out that you
can create a situation
where the artist or
the child in
kindergarten who's being
offered rewards for
painting in kindergarten,
whether it's adult or
child it doesn't matter,
they will spend less time on it,
they will be less personally
invested and the work itself
will be less creative.
It turns out there are
these creativity experts,
they can look at
this and assess this.
The other problem is
this and I'm going
to point directly at
sticker charts mainly because
one of the questions I
got originally before
I even came here today,
thank you Anthony for
passing those along,
was about sticker charts.
One of the problems with
sticker charts is this,
often we use sticker charts
in schools to shape behavior.
There are a bunch of programs
out there that do this,
there's class Dojo, there's
sticker charts at home,
were you good at school today?
If so, you get a big sticker.
Schools of character, schools
that are really really
deeply concerned with
character education
don't use sticker charts.
Because what sticker charts
teach children to do is to be
good only when people
are watching, right?
Because what is
the benefit of doing
the right thing
unless someone is
there to give you the sticker.
If we're teaching children to
only be good when
someone is watching,
that's a problem
because schools of
character one of
the things that they
do is they talk about making
sure kids know the right,
making sure kids do
the right and doing
the right not just with people
watching but when it's
just the right thing to do.
When I talk about this stuff,
I'm often reminded of admissions
counselor at Dartmouth.
She's no longer there
but when she was
there she wrote
this lovely op-ed for
The New York Times about
who they admitted to
Dartmouth and why.
And she talked very
specifically about
this one kid that they
decided to admit to
Dartmouth because he had
a letter of recommendation
from the janitor,
the one of the grounds
keepers at his high school,
and the groundskeeper said,
"This is the kind
of kid that picks up
trash on campus when
no one is watching."
And this woman at
Dartmouth said,
"That's what we want
for our community."
So, that sort of stuff
is really important.
Now, when I talk about
extrinsic motivators,
I want to clarify
there's different kinds.
There's the kinds that
are perceived as positive
like money for grades
or stuff for grades.
Usually when I go
around to schools,
I talk to the kids during
the day and then I do
professional development
with the teachers in
the afternoon and then I
talk to the parents
in the evening.
And I do this little thing
with the kids,
what I say to them is,
"All teachers and
staff close your eyes.
Now, raise your hand kids
if you get paid for grades."
Depending on the
school district around
15 percent or so
between 15 and 20 percent
raised their hands.
Then I said, "Put
your hands down.
Now raise your hands
if you get anything in
return for grade stuff
in return for grades."
And it goes up a little
bit maybe like 20,
25 percent of the hands go up,
depending on
the school district.
And then I have them
put their hands down and
I make sure the teachers
and the staff
all have their eyes closed
make them promise
and then I say,
"Think about this really
carefully before you do
it but raise your hands
if you really
truly believe that
your parents love you
more when you perform
well in school versus
when you don't."
In middle school, among
middle school kids,
about 80 percent of the hands go
up and among high school kids
about 90 percent
of the hands go up.
So extrinsic motivators
can be love.
They can be us
loving our kids more
showing more love
when they're giving us
those grades that we
want from them and
no I'm not an idiot
I know you can't
we just react emotionally
differently when
kids are doing
poorly versus when
kids are doing well
because we're worried.
We want our kids to do well in
school but what I'm
talking about here
more is giving them
the idea that we
really and truly love
them more when they give us
those letters we want from them.
There can also be negative
extrinsic motivators and
when I'm talking about
perception and those
can be things like,
"You are grounded if you have
anything less than a B
minus average," or,
"We are going to take away
your devices if you have
less than a whatever."
And then there are
a couple that you
wouldn't think of as extrinsic
motivators but they are.
Let's say for example,
if someone could
log onto a computer
anytime they want and see
their children's grades like 10,
20, 30, 50 times a
day heck just keep
it up on the desktop and just
hit refresh all day long.
And it sounds like
I'm making a joke
here and sort of using hyperbole
but I'm not because from
our perspective as school
administrators and teachers,
we see how many times you login.
We know and we talk about you.
Mainly we talk about you because
we are concerned as
teachers and administrators,
that when you're
logging on constantly on
the computer that
you are not having,
channels of communication with
your child may not be ideal.
Because it looks
like the parents,
from my perspective anyway,
the parents that log
on the most tend to
be the ones who don't really
have really good open channels
of communication
with their children.
Now, there's another kind of
extrinsic motivator that you
also may not think about,
and that's tracking
your kids on their phones.
And that's called surveillance.
As is using the portal.
And I'm not saying we can't
use any of these things,
I'm just saying
that we have to be
aware of them because if
their effect is to undermine
motivation, and learning,
as I'll get to in a second,
then we're doing
our kids a disservice,
if we're relying on
those things in order
to shape their behavior.
Again with extrinsic motivators,
one of the things we have
to keep in mind is in
the short-term they work
great, they are fantastic.
If you want to boost motivation,
if you want to sort of
get the kid off
the starting block,
then extrinsic motivators
can work great.
If you want to offer your kid,
you know a nice
sparkly Paris soccer
shorts for going to
that first soccer practice,
then great do that.
But you can't have that be
your strategy moving forward
because it will undermine
their motivation and
their investment over time.
So, here's what we do want.
We want intrinsic motivation.
Again I am not an idiot.
I don't think that if you
just do the things
I'm going to tell you
about in a second
that your kid will
be like 'quadratic formula,
I got it. I'm so excited'.
But you can up the chances
that they will be
engaged for the sake of
the learning itself
instead of for
the sake of those numbers
and points and grades.
Okay. If we're really lucky,
the highest form of
intrinsic motivation is this
little something called flow.
Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi
talks about flow.
It's that state where you're
doing something
that's difficult.
It's not too easy,
it's not too hard,
but it's difficult enough to
really engage
your body or your mind.
For me it's
cross-country skiing.
It's hard for me, it's
a difficult thing,
and I'm not doing it because
I'm going to win a race.
I'm never I'm going to win
a race, but it's challenging.
It's challenging to
my mind and to my body,
and so time and
space falls away.
For some people it's music.
You know that's sort of
the classic flow state
is often described as like jazz,
where you're so engaged in it
at the time and
space falls away.
You don't get flow
when you're being
extrinsically motivated,
forced to do something for
the sake of something else.
And if you think about extrinsic
motivators for a second,
when I was young we used to have
this thing where if we read
a certain amount of
the summer pizza,
Hut would give us
coupons for pizza.
Think about that
for just a second.
What's the most valuable thing
in that equation?
Books or the pizza?
Well the pizza is the reward.
I mean if we really wanted to
make books be
the valuable thing we
would give kids books for
eating a lot of pizza, right?
Okay. Intrinsic motivation.
Edward DCci talks about
intrinsic motivation
in his book and why
we do what we do,
the science of self-motivation.
It requires three
things. Number one.
It requires autonomy,
which is kind of like
independence but a
little different.
It has to do with
control over the details.
Well, for those of you
in the room with toddlers
you know full well
you do not say,
"It's cold, would you like to
wear a hat today?"
No, no, no, no.
You say, "It's cold,
do you want to wear
the red hat or the blue hat?"
Right? Because then you're
getting some buy-in,
because they get
to have a little
autonomy over that decision.
In the town where we live,
we're not big enough,
I live in a very small town
in New Hampshire,
we're not big enough to
have our own high school.
So kids have school choice.
And parents just why and
worry and worry over
the choice because it's,
you know it's such an
important decision, and it is.
But I always come
back with, well,
but if you let your kid
choose then you're automatically
getting more buy-in,
especially since
the high schools we have to
choose from are all
pretty darn good.
And if you get buy-in
from your kid you're
more likely to have buy-in,
and that's autonomy.
Control over the details.
So autonomy number
one, number two,
competence which I'm
so sorry to tell you
parents is not the same
thing as confidence.
Confidence we are really
good at as parents,
we're not so good at instilling
competence and I'll come
back to that in a minute.
And finally, connection.
Connection when I talk to
teachers doing professional
development is this I
could spend 90 minutes
just talking about
connection because it
has to do with relevance,
and this thing
called self-efficacy,
and getting rid of
learned helplessness and
all this stuff
that's really fun.
If your kids have teachers that
make a subject come alive in
a way that makes them think,
"I could go out into the world
and do stuff with
this information",
then please start sending
thank-you notes because
that's really where the secret
source is with education.
For parents it's
really pretty simple,
and I'll come back
to that at the end.
Alright, autonomy.
In the book I talk about
the work of Wendy Grownek.
She does research
on the way how we
parent affects
kids motivation in learning.
And one of the cool experiments
she did was this.
She had mother infant pairs,
and I'm sorry dads it just
happened to be mothers
in this experiment.
Mother infant pairs
came to her lab,
and she designed a task for
the kids that was
engaging and exciting,
something they would want to do,
but something that was a
little bit hard for them.
She wanted it to be
challenging on purpose.
Because she really
was interested
not whether or
not the kid could,
you know how they did the task,
but how they reacted
when they got frustrated.
And the instructions she
gave the parents were
really quite generic on purpose.
Be there with your child
while they complete this task.
Because she wanted that to
be open to interpretation.
Some of the parents were
there while the child
completed the task.
They let the child have
control over how
the task was completed.
If the kid got frustrated,
they were there
to be supportive,
they were what's called
autonomy supportive.
They were there and supportive
of the child's autonomy,
but they didn't take over.
And those were referred to again
as autonomy supportive parents.
And then some of
the other parents,
and I'm sure we don't
know any of these,
were all over the task.
They told the kid how to
do it, and where to do it,
in what order to do the steps,
and laid out the steps
very clearly.
First do this, then do this.
And by the way that behavior
was amplified when she
told the parents that
their child's work
would be evaluated by
other parents after
the experiment.
That went through
the roof. So these parents
over here were called directive.
Wendy also uses
the word controlling,
but I'll stick with directive
because I might
piss you off more
later and so I'm
going to stick with
the nice words now, directive.
Autonomy, supportive, directive.
Here's where it
gets interesting.
Then she has the children
come back with the parents.
This time she separates
the mothers from the children,
and gives the children
another task that's engaging,
exciting, something they want to
do but again a little
bit frustrating.
The children of the autonomy
supportive parents got
excited about the task,
and engaged in the task,
and got started, and got going,
and got frustrated,
but were able to kind
of take a breath,
look at it another way,
think about the
instructions again,
and sort of finish.
Almost all of them
finished the task.
The children of the directive
or controlling parents,
they got into the task got
excited about the task,
got frustrated, and almost
all of them cried and gave up.
They were missing
whatever emotional wherewithal
they needed in order to
sort of stick with it,
and be okay with
being frustrated.
Being okay with being
frustrated sort of is at
the heart of
this whole equation.
Because kids who
can't be frustrated,
and we all know what
these kids look like, right?
You take them to
their first gymnastics class
and they can't do a cartwheel
perfectly and they're
like, "Oh no, that's it.
Forget it. I'll never
be able to do it ever."
And that's really hard to get
past and I'll talk
a little bit about
that before we're done,
and how to get over that.
But when you can't be
frustrated there's a lot
of learning that
can't happen too.
And the way that these
directive parents are, you know,
feeding the kid information and
saying okay first do
this, second do this,
and not wanting to see
our kids get frustrated,
that is so natural.
I hate seeing my kids
get frustrated.
I hate seeing my students
I have the answers.
It would be so great
if I just gave them
the information and then
no one has to be
frustrated ever,
and frankly it makes me
look like a better teacher.
Because now my students are
getting the right answer,
whether or not they
really understand
the information very well,
that's a whole other question.
Why do I care so much?
Well, when kids are
really, really little,
a kid who cries and gives up,
and can't stick with something,
that's frustrating as a parent,
but eventually they're
going to end up in
my classroom, or a classroom.
And this is where
the rubber really
hits the road because
what ends up happening is,
kids who can't be frustrated
can't learn as well.
I would always rather
have a perfectly average,
and I use the word
perfectly on purpose,
a perfectly average child
of average intelligence.
I would much rather
have a kid that's of
average intelligence but
who can be frustrated,
than a kid who is brilliant
beyond measure but gives
up the second they feel
like they maybe can't
do something right.
Because that kid who can be
frustrated is more
teachable, and here's why.
One of the most
powerful teaching tools
I have as a teacher,
there are two I talk
about frequently.
One of them I talk about
mostly with teachers,
but the one I talked
about with parents is
this one called
desirable difficulties.
There's a fantastic book that
it's on the bibliography
that came out a couple of
years ago called
Make It Stick from
Harvard University Press,
three authors.
They talk about desirable
difficulties in this book
because it's so powerful.
Here's what desirable
difficulties can do.
If I give all of you
a paragraph about
jellyfish and half of
you have a paragraph
that's easy to read.
The text is really clear,
the words you don't have
to look them up it's
all in language
you can understand.
And half of you have a piece of
paper that's difficult to read.
Maybe some of
the letters are reversed,
maybe some of the words are more
difficult then you
have to look them up
but essentially the information
is the same and I say in
five minutes I'm
going to give you
a quiz on this paragraph
on jellyfish.
You people over
here who have the
difficult to read
piece of paper,
you are going to slay
them on the quiz in
the short-term and
then in the long-term
if you all come back and take
this quiz again in two weeks,
you're really going to
kill them on the quiz.
Because what your brain
has done when you
had to work a little bit
harder to get information in,
your brain said, "Oh
this is not short-term
memory stuff."
Short-term memory stuff is
like the number
for the pizza guy.
Something that you can
keep in your head for a
second but then it's
fine, it can go away.
When you have to work
a little bit harder
to get the information
in your head,
your brain says, "Oh No No.
This is long-term memory stuff."
Clearly this is important.
This is more
challenging it causes
the brain automatically
to do this thing called
encoding where it takes
the information moves it from
short-term to long-term memory.
Short-term memory is not a place
where we can manipulate
information very
well and it's
definitely not a place
where we store stuff long-term.
So if we want kids to do
"oh I don't know" Know
information well
enough to be able to
apply it in a novel situation,
it needs to be in long-term it
can't just be sitting
in short-term and
what you people did
over here to learn about
the jellyfish was you crammed.
You heard you had
five minutes to learn it all,
and so you just shoved
it in your head.
Maybe those of you who brought
highlighters with
you, you highlighted.
Please let's take highlighters
away from kids because all they
do is highlight everything
and they say, "That's okay.
I'll memorize all of it."
That's cramming. Those
of us who have done
any amount of cramming in
our lives know it does not work.
It definitely doesn't
work over the short-term,
it really doesn't work
over the long-term.
Those of us who cram we try
to shove it all in there,
stick a cork in
our ear and then walk
this way to the task so it
doesn't all dribble out.
Some fun information when
I get to talk to kids,
I talk to them a lot about
sleep and the
importance of sleep
because I can't overestimate
the importance of sleep.
One of the pieces of information
I give them is there are
studies that have shown
that if you have one hour,
you know the are kids
like, "Oh one more hour.
I'll turn the lights
off in one more hour.
Just want to do
one more hour of studying."
And you're like oh my kid is
so diligent and fantastic.
What you can tell your child is,
one extra hour of
sleep is more powerful
because of the
memory consolidation,
than one more hour of studying.
So please when I tell kids
how much sleep
they're supposed to be
getting they just laugh me.
Teenagers are supposed
to still be getting
around nine and a
half hours of sleep
at night and they're
getting nowhere near that.
A lot of kids are getting
somewhere closer
to six and a half.
And in terms of
learning it's sleep.
Sleep is one of the most
important things we can do.
So, tell your kid if they
say "I want one more hour."
Say "Look I learned from
this woman Miss Lei She's
an education researcher
and she found out
that one more hour of sleep
is more valuable than."
And that's why the American
Academy of Pediatrics
came together a couple
of years ago to issue
a statement saying
that schools should
open no earlier than 8.30
in the morning because
an extra hour of
sleep is such a powerful
thing for teenagers.
Just on a little tangent.
If your teenager
say late at night,
"Am just not sleepy yet."
They're not lying,
they really aren't.
Teenagers have this thing
called sleep phase delay.
Where their brain
squirts out melatonin
and other chemicals
and makes them
sleepy later but
the other problem is that one of
the other things
that teenagers brains
don't do very well is
perceive how tired they are.
So they could be
exhausted and they're
not as good as adults
are at knowing that.
Which is why I have
to tap on their shoulder when
they're drooling on the desk.
It's also why when schools do
move their school start
times an hour later,
not only does it improve
test scores, grades,
behavior, it decreases
the number of
car accidents
caused by teenagers.
An hour extra of sleep is
incredibly powerful thing.
Really really powerful.
Okay. And by the way if you get
the American Academy
of Pediatrics to come
together and issue
a policy statement on something,
it's a miracle and it really
means that they're serious.
So when they come out
and say schools should
start no earlier than
8.30 for high school,
this is not for younger kids
because they don't have
the sleep phase delay issue
but for high school.
It's important stuff.
It's really worth listening.
And yes it's incredibly
difficult to move
school start times because
of sports and extracurriculars.
It really seems to be worth it.
These school districts
that have done it.
Okay. Autonomy, still
overhearing competence.
The difference
between competence and
confidence is really
important to know.
Confidence is
that empty feeling of,
"Yeah my parents tell me
all the time how smart I am.
It's going to be
fine. It'll be great."
That kid who comes to
Kindergarten and says,
"I'm here and I'm
the best reader in the class
because my parents told me so."
That's great.
Optimism is fantastic.
I am an optimistic person,
I think it's what keeps
me from just falling
down with despair over the state
of education some days.
But it needs to be paired
with experience and
competence is confidence
paired with actual experience,
doing something, screwing it up,
figuring out what to
leave behind and what to
bring forward with you and
trying and doing it again.
I got to work on
this really fun television show
for really young kids called
the Stinky and Dirty show,
it runs on Amazon.
And in that show we have
these two characters who
have to get these tasks done and
inevitably their first
sought of ideas about
how they're going to
get these tasks done are
classic like
preschooler tat like,
"We'll wait for the moon to come
up and then we'll
throw a last sue
over the moon and it'll pull
the bowling ball
up or whatever."
And they come to find
that that's not going to
work but they don't
say, "Well that's it.
I'm too stupid to do this."
They come up with that
because they're supportive
of each other and
because they are working
toward a common goal
and because they're
resilient little
creatures, little
characters there.
A dump truck and a digger.
They move forward with
the next iteration of the plan.
That's competence.
In the classroom
it looks like this,
I give kids something
let's say we're
in Latin class sorry if
I give anyone flashbacks.
And I'm teaching the nominative
and accusative case
and I say "Okay.
Here's the sentence Puella,
Puerum, Ahmad, the girl
loves the boys."
Standard word order
in Latin and they
get comfortable
with that and then
I go over here and I say "Okay.
This one's a little harder.
Puerum, Puella, Ahmad."
And they freak out at first.
They're like "That
makes no sense.
You're missing the wrong place."
And then they calm
down and I say,
"No you have
the skills to do this.
Just be quiet for a second."
In my classroom you're
not allowed to speak for
a few seconds after I present
a question because that favors
the extroverts to throw
their hands up in
the air and they like,
and they don't know what
they're going to say.
They have no idea. But
you got to say that let.
I know because I'm one of those.
In law school I figured as
my hand was up in the air,
something would fall out
of my mouth that made
sense and plus if I
volunteered enough,
that would mean that
maybe I wouldn't get
called on like randomly.
It totally works.
But introverted kids often
in the classroom need
a few more moments to think.
And so, that was a big discovery
I made as a teacher,
is that if I stopped
calling on kids right away,
I could actually level
the playing field a bit.
So the problem
with these kids is,
then they say, "Oh, I don't
know. That's so hard."
But then, they realize,
okay, no, no, no.
I did it this way over here.
Mrs. Lahey has faith in me.
She thinks I can do it
all. I see what you did.
You just reversed the two words.
I get it. And then,
I give them something
even harder.
And whether that's in
the form of homework,
and I do not have time to talk
about the way I
feel about homework,
I've written about
it extensively at
The New York Times
and The Atlantic.
The research is pretty clear.
I don't have time
to talk about that.
But if I give them, let's say,
homework that's built
on what we did in class,
but is a little bit harder,
incorporating, I don't know,
some of those desirable
difficulties in,
I need the kids to
be able to stay calm
and to trust that I'm
not just putting
them out there with
this difficult stuff that
they can't possibly do.
And it's the kids who can
be frustrated who
can push through.
It's the kids who feel
competent, not just confident.
The confidence game really
comes out of the
self-esteem movement.
Total failure by the way.
Self-esteem movement, what we
hoped was that if
we told our kids
enough times how fantastic and
wonderful and gifted
and talented they are,
that they would have this Star
Wars force field
of wonderfulness
around them so that when
they would go off to
school and if someone
said something mean,
it would like pew and
go off to the side.
But they would
come home with like
their force field of
wonderfulness intact.
It doesn't work that way.
The research on self-esteem
and praise shows,
there's a study
that came out just
recently, was
really interesting.
It showed that for kids who
have really low self-esteem,
the kids we really need to buoy
up with our words of
support and praise,
if we tell those kids that
they're so smart, gifted,
talented, perfect, we don't
raise their self-esteem.
We lower it.
Because for kids like that,
and I often remember myself
sitting there in Algebra one,
thinking, ''Oh my gosh!
I'm the only person who does
not understand any of this.''
And if I had gone home and
my parents were telling me
constantly how gifted I was,
my school reality and
home reality would not match.
And that is really
disturbing to kids.
When I speak to kids,
one my favorite grades
to speak to is
sixth grade because they
have the best the questions.
And recently, I was at
a school in New York.
And this one kid
raised his hand,
and he said, ''Yeah.
I don't know if
it's just me or not,
but my parents tell me I am
perfect at everything I do,
and I just don't think
that can be right.''
And I said, ''It's
not just you sweetie.
And as wonderful is,
as I think I assume you are.
It's probably true that you're
not perfect at everything,
and that's good
because we shouldn't
be perfect at everything
right off the bad.
That means we're probably
not trying very hard.''
So, telling kids how
wonderful and perfect
they are all the time can
mess with their heads.
Not only that,
those of you who are
familiar at all with Carol Dweck
and her work on mindsets,
if you've only read articles
about Carol Dweck and mindsets,
I would encourage you
to read the whole book,
because the way
journalism intends,
I hope this doesn't come
as a shocker to anyone.
But what often happens is,
I go to my editor, and I say,
''I have this article
I want to write on
this amazing breakthrough
education theory,
and I'm going to need
like 2,000 more words.''
And she's like,
''Okay. Sounds great.
You can write it, but
you get 500 words.''
So we tend to oversimplify
just because that's how.
They're all terribly
editors or terribly
concerned that your attention
span is about this big.
So we need to prove them wrong.
So I go off and I
have to write about
something in making a list,
which is ridiculous.
Those of you who have only
read about Carol
Dweck's research,
what you'd probably think it
means is that we
should only praise
our children for their effort
and never tell them that
they're smart, which is stupid.
Because if I were to run at
that door and I
don't know that I
have to press that bar right
there to make the door unlatch,
but I just keep running at
the door and bashing
my body against it,
and you keep saying, ''Oh, Jess,
good effort, keep going.''
You are terrible teachers.
I'm not learning very much.
I'm not going to
trust you anymore.
We're sort of, neither one
of us is getting anywhere.
But if you're
supportive in a way
that a lot of teachers know
works pretty well
in the classroom is,
''Oh, I see you're
having some problems.
Stop for a second.
Look at the door. Is there
anything you're not thinking of?
Is there anything you
haven't considered?"
That's what great teaching and
parenting looks
like because that
allows the child to have
some autonomy over
their learning and figure out,
''Oh, what am I not
thinking about?''
So, competence, overconfidence.
One of the ways we
can do that is by
praising them for
the process part,
talking a lot about the process
as opposed to the end product.
Carol Dweck's research
is really interesting.
Here's a quick primer.
She gives a math quiz
to everyone.
Lets say, this is
a math quiz for all of you,
and it's right in
your sweet spot.
It's not going to be
too hard or too easy.
To half of you, she comes
back and her praise is,
''Oh sweetie, you got
an eight out of 10.
You must be so smart.''
And then, the other
half she says,
''Oh, you got eight out of 10.
You must have worked so hard.''
And then she gives all of
the kids a slightly harder quiz.
And when the results come in,
the kids who had been
praised for how smart they
are do the same or
a little bit worse,
which it's a harder
quiz of course.
The kids who've been praised
for how hard they worked
do the same or a
little bit better,
which is interesting
to me as a teacher,
but not as interesting as this.
Because then she
says, ''Thank you
so much for being
a part of this today.
Now, before you go,
I have these challenge
questions. They're hard.
You may not be able
to do all of them.
Who want some?''
The kids who were praised
for how smart they are want
nothing to do with
the challenge problems.
However, the kids who
were praised for how
hard they worked want
the challenge problems.
In fact, one girl in
the experiment said,
''well, of course, we want
the challenge problems.
Those are the fun
ones. Those are
the ones we have to work out.''
Again, I come back
to this discussion
of desirable difficulties.
If you people don't want
the challenge problems,
you're probably not stretching
yourself and learning as well.
So that's interesting.
But again,
I'm really really interested
in how we can create
learning environments that
are not conducive to cheating,
that kids don't feel like
they have to cheat in.
I'm really fascinated by
academic dishonesty and
how we can fix that.
Here's what I love,
is then I say,
Ms. Carol Dweck says,
I love pretending to be
Carol Dweck, she says, ''Now,
before you go, if
everyone could flip over
their piece of paper,
I'm going to give this quiz
at another school.
And if you could flip
over your piece of paper
and write down your experience
of taking this quiz and
what your score was,
that would be really helpful
for those other kids."
You people over here who
were praised for your effort,
how hard you worked,
you wrote down
your experience and you
wrote down your quiz score.
Almost 50 percent of you
people who were praised
for how smart you are,
lied about your score and
artificially inflated it.
When I ask kids,
again with those six graders
but I've asked
this question to kids as
young as fourth-grade,
"Why do you think the kids who
were praised for being smart,
don't want the
challenge problems
and lie about their scores?"
And they're like, "Well, dah,
if you've told us
that you're smart,
we're not going
to screw that up.
We need for you to
keep believing that.
We need the kids around us,
our friends to keep
believing that,
and that means that
everything has to look easy,
and if we take the challenge
problems we're probably going to
get some wrong and you're
not going to think
we're smart anymore,
and if other people are
going to know about
our quizzes, well,
we're going to lie
a little bit and
say that we got
a higher score than we did".
James M. Lang, who wrote a book
called Cheating Lessons about
creating learning environments
where kids don't
need to cheat said,
"It's really clear.
If you want to create
a classroom full of cheaters,
just keep telling them
how smart they are."
I don't think it's
quite that simple,
the rest of the book
goes on to explain
how the way we assess
kids right now is probably
not the best way to do it.
And again, I don't
have time to talk
about how I feel about grading,
and how I feel about
various forms of assessment,
I've written about
it extensively at
the Atlantic and the New York
Times, you can go find it.
And the piece of
the Atlantic is called Why
Letter Grades
Deserve an F. Turns
out the way we test
kids doesn't tend to work
very well for learning anyway.
Okay. Autonomy,
competence, connection.
Again for teachers, this
all comes down to relevance,
this all comes down
that teacher whose,
you know sometimes
these teachers have these,
you can't put your finger on it,
you don't know
what exactly it is
but they make
learning come alive.
That teacher who
comes in and says,
"I found out
last night that there
was an earthquake in Peru,
and so let me show you
some pictures of the bridges
that fell down and
the bridges that stayed up,
and let's see what we can
gather from looking at
these two different
kinds of bridges.
And okay, here's some bridges
over here that fell down
and oh my gosh,
they're all rectangles.
And look at these bridges
over here that are arches.
Those are still standing.
And this is geometry class.
And did you know that
the people who built
those bridges were
once kids just like you
who sat in these
geometry classes and
found out about things
like the Roman aqueducts,
where the arches are what
have kept them standing for
thousands of years and why
this kind of bridge over here,
is likely not to work?"
And those kids not
only learn about
shapes that work in geometry
and why those shapes work,
but what they also learn is,
"Oh my gosh, I could do that.
I could build bridges that
will hold up when
there's an earthquake".
That's called self-efficacy.
Self-efficacy is an incredibly
important element of
any education program
which is knowing that
not only do you have
the ability to change
your own life too,
that the decisions you make
will make a difference.
It's why kids who
are in really traumatic
situations as children,
children who live in abuse,
children who live with
people who are drug
and alcohol addicted,
they learn that there's not
a lot they can do to
change their environment.
They lose their sense of
self-efficacy and
that's a disaster.
Not just for their lives
but for their learning.
It's one of the many reasons
that kids who have
experienced trauma
at a young age,
just don't learn as well.
And not only that,
one of the things
we know about learning is that
the very fastest way to
interrupt learning is
to introduce stress.
It's why often at the end of
these talks I'll
get a question about
the impact of competition
on children and learning,
and I have to say that's
a very complicated question
because it turns out for
some kids, it's helpful.
Competition for
some kids it's fantastic.
It can lead to better learning,
can lead to higher achievement.
But for some kids, it's a
disaster because you could have
a kid who knows their
multiplication tables really,
really well, and
the second you say,
"This is a timed
worksheet", they fall apart.
It's why Joe Bowler who wrote
the book Mathematical
Mindsets says,
the very first thing
we need to do if we
really want to teach Math
effectively in this country,
is stop timing worksheets
because mastery and
being able to do Math
fast are not the same thing
and it creates a lot
of Math anxiety
and that comes as
a person who had for much
of my life really,
really horrible Math anxiety.
I was told in seventh grade
that I wasn't a Math person.
So, when I went back to take
algebra one again when I was
45 because one of my friends
was teaching the class,
and it was right next
to where my office was,
and I told you about all that
free time I had when I was
a middle school teacher.
Yeah. I tossed
that one prep period
and I sat in onto her class
and I took algebra one at
the same time my older son
took algebra one.
We took it together. And I
took it with my students.
And I learned that
I'm not bad at Math,
Math is hard. Math
is challenging.
And so, one of the things that
happens in this competence,
confidence area is,
we have these kids,
we tell them early
on in their lives,
"You were born good at Math.
You're just so great at Math."
And what happens to
these kids is that they
start to believe that it's
always supposed to
be easy for them,
because if it's
not easy for them,
then maybe they aren't as
smart as we're
telling them they are.
When I went back and retook
algebra one in my 40s,
my mentor for that
was Steven Strogatz,
who's a Math professor
at Cornell.
And he says, one of
the things he says is,
we got to stop telling kids
that they're just good at
Math because Math will get
hard for everyone otherwise,
we wouldn't have proofs that
we can't solve out there.
We wouldn't have had
Fermat's Last Theorem
sitting around for
as long as we did.
For those kids who are
told that they're
just good at Math,
they're going to be just good
at Math for a little while,
and it's going to be
going great and they're
going to be doing
really, really well,
and then it's going
to get hard for
them whether that's
in sixth grade,
or tenth grade, or
freshman year of college,
it just happens
to a lot of kids.
How they respond to
that when it does
get challenging is everything.
That determines how well
they're going to do over time.
There's a lot of
kids actually who
hit that moment and
just drop it and say,
"Oh, this was
all Impostor Syndrome.
This was all a big mistake and I
wasn't really ever as
smart as I thought I was."
So for teachers,
this relevant stuff is
like multilayered, and amazing.
And again, if your kids have
teachers that are
making learning
relevant and making kids
feel like they
have self-efficacy,
oh love those teachers up.
They're just fantastic.
For parents it's
really, really simple.
Connection for parents
comes down to two things.
You have to love
the child you have,
not the child you wish you had.
Not some fantasy of
the child that you
developed based
on all the things
you wish you had done, "Oh,
if I had just practiced piano,
I could be so good now, so,
I'm going to sit on my kid
and make them practice piano."
All of those fantasies you have
about who your child could be,
may not be the child
that's sitting right
in front of you.
And our kids know it when
we're not loving them,
when we don't see them.
So, love the kid you have
not the kid you wish you had,
and don't just love your kids
based on their performance.
And I know, I'm like,
"I would never do
that except when they
come home with a test
that they're really
excited to show us",
they're like, look what.
Show it to us and it's
an A and we flipout,
and were like put it on
Instagram and put it on
Facebook and let's live
tweet and move, move, move.
And you freak out.
They're getting
the message that,
oh here we go,
I've given them the good stuff,
the stuff they love.
But then they come home a
little more sedate with the F,
I'm sorry, B minus, that's
what we call an F now, right?
Yeah. Okay, with that F
or B minus and we show it,
they show it to us
and we're silent.
That silence, by the way,
when I talk to kids,
I make it really clear
that this parenting thing
is so important to us
that we have to like,
look for just the right words
to say just the right thing.
But ask any psychologist,
that silence,
that's withdrawal
of love based on
performance and it's one of
the most emotionally devastating
things we can do to kids.
Unless you think that you
would never like I did,
remember when I
ask those kids how
many of you believe that
your parents love you
more when you bring them
the grades and scores that
they want versus the ones they
don't and you get
those 80 to 90 percent.
I mean, I think it's lower
for middle school
because I think
middle school kids still
have some faith in us.
They're still like oh,
they're trying to do
the right thing I can tell.
And it's the reason
also that the heart of
the gift of failure is
on middle school because
really that's
our moment to really
allow them to make mistakes and
allow them to learn
from those mistakes.
So autonomy, competence
and connection.
Those are the three pieces that
we need to bring
together in some way.
And I don't want to go
too long today and I want
to leave plenty of
time for questions,
but bringing that together
is a really amazing thing.
I'm so fortunate I get
a lot of letters from parents
and I love all of them.
And most of them say things
like, "Oh you're so right.
I let my kid you know
put her dishes in
the dishwasher and
she was so proud of
herself and she's becoming
more and more competent."
And I love those
letters. I love them.
But I love these even more,
the ones that I get that says,
"You know what, I gave
my kid more autonomy."
I sort of said,
"You know Sweetie,
I think I've been
doing too much for you,
and I actually think
you're able to do much more
than I give you credit for.
So, this is now going
to be your thing."
And usually that's homework.
Homework is
a good place to start.
"This is your thing now.
I'm not going to be
checking the portal.
I'm not going to be sitting
right there with
you while you do
your homework because I
have faith that
this is your thing."
And then talking really,
really clearly about
your expectations
and your consequences
around homework.
Expectations could be you know,
for us was for a long time
it was just you'll do
your homework until we realize
that he was doing his homework.
This is Phin I'm talking
about because his story
is in the book.
He was doing his homework,
he just wasn't getting
the homework into
the backpack and taking the
homework out of the backpack.
So, this was, you know,
our expectations and
our strategies had to shift.
And then making
the consequences really,
really clear about what
will happen if they're
not meeting those expectations.
And by the way our consequences
that we tend to come up with as
adults make perfect sense to us
sometimes or don't
make any sense to kids.
Kids, younger kids in
particular, their frontal lobe,
our frontal lobe
is the last part
of our brain to fully cook.
And that's where all
the organization,
the executive function,
time management,
organization of all that stuff,
the locker and the classes,
and the notebooks and keeping
the pants up and
tying the shoes,
all that stuff happens
in executive function.
And executive function in
our frontal lobe is not fully
cooked until we're
in our early 20s.
I used to say, "Yeah,
you can just wait until
your kids brain is fully baked."
And then I realized that
cooked maybe works
better because fully
baked just has the wrong
connotation about it.
But waiting until their brain,
sometimes there are just places
in life like middle
school where we're
asking them to do way more than
their brain can actually
handle which is,
as I come back to the magic
of middle school
because my job is to
watch kids grow up
all day long and
help them come up with
strategies to fix them.
And anytime those
moments are stolen,
that's really difficult
for them and for us.
Autonomy, competence,
connection, because
that connection part
here is what can happen.
When we do give
our kids more autonomy,
let's say around
homework, and we back off,
the letters then that I get are
not just my kid has become
more competent which I love,
but our relationship
has improved.
We talk about stuff
that matters not
just the stuff that
I want to talk about.
When I sat in recently
on a panel of freshmen,
sorry, seniors in
high school who were giving
advice to parents of
incoming freshmen.
One of the parents said,
"What's the biggest,
the most important piece
of advice you could give us
about how to help our kids have
a good first year
in high school?"
And the kids said, "Stop
talking to them about grades
every minute of the day.
They know grades are important."
Maybe, and in the book I talk
about a possible alternative,
maybe we could talk to
them about their goals.
Maybe we could talk to
them about what they love,
what they're interested in.
Talk to them about what their
personal goals are for school as
opposed to what
their grades are that day.
Because then, when you get into
that stuff that's when you
get to really know your kids.
You get to know the kid
that's in front of you.
The kid, your kid,
not that fantasy kid
you wish you had.
That's what sort of allows
kids to feel like they
can trust us to have
conversations that
are a little bit
difficult about maybe
where they screwed up,
because they know
that we're not just
loving them based
on performance,
we're loving them because we
love them and that
we support them.
All right, I'm
going to stop there
because I could keep
going on for hours,
but I'm assuming
there are questions,
I happen to know there
are some questions
before I even came into this.
On YouTube, I have a series
called Gift to Failure Facts.
A frequently asked questions,
answering the most common
questions I get via email.
So, they're like how to help
kids who coast, how to help,
parent perfectionist kids,
what about my special needs kid,
is there a different
message there?
Should I feel stupid for
trusting the school when they
told me what I really
need to focus on
his grades and points in scores.
Really, it's called,
should I feel
stupid for being duped
by a flawed system.
There are a lot of flaws with
our education system right now
and I couldn't write a book
that appended all of that,
I had to say, "Here's
what we've got right now,
how do we work within that?"
So, focusing for example,
on goals as opposed to grades
is a great place to start,
but I'm happy to
take any questions.
What if I told you I
know what your questions
are and hopefully
you can ask them.
Someone's going to ask me
about musical instruments and
when they are allowed
to let their kid
quit that's one too.
I get that one a lot.
My kid has been playing
soccer since she was
six and now she's 14
and she's really really,
really good but she
says she doesn't
want to play soccer
anymore, what should I do?
Should I let her quit? That's
a question I get a lot.
>> What's the answer?
What's the answer?
Honestly, certain things
we're talking about
whether that's music
or athletics really
depends on your
priorities as a family.
Often this question
is about sports or
music and so I'll use
those two examples.
In my home, we're not,
we like music but we are not
an intensely musical family.
A friend of mine who has
a very musical family it is
a non-negotiable that
their children will play
some instrument
until they are 18,
that's just a non-negotiable.
It's not going any other
way so for them
quitting an instrument
means fine what are
you going to take up
next at which point
the child says,
"No, I've already
been doing the cello
for a while I guess I'll
just stick with that."
In our house, I
tell a story often.
My son, his older brother.
Our next door neighbor had
a piano that they were
getting rid of and I'm like
perfect because I've read
the research showing that if
your kid could do music that
they're going to be better
at math and so I really need
to do the music thing in them
and piano that's perfect.
And so we wheeled
the piano down from
their house into
our house and we got him
lessons and we had
the honeymoon period where
it's all great for like a week,
maybe two weeks and then
it was fighting constantly.
Constantly you have to practice.
Here's what you
need to practice.
How are you going to practice.
What do I need to do?
Have you practiced yet?
And it was really undermining
our relationship and for me
a non-negotiable is
our relationship and so,
and for me whether or not
he plays piano honestly,
I could care less
really and truly.
So we wheeled the piano
down the street to
the next suckers house and
it can only go downhill
and we're on a big hill so
it came down and then it
went down to my friend
Vicky's house and
then it went down
from their house down.
But then what was
really interesting
is a couple of years later,
my husband plays
guitar and my older son
saw my husband playing
guitar and said,
you know I think I might
want to do some guitar
and so he took some lessons,
he learned out very
quickly that it wasn't
the piano or the guitar
that he was not enjoying,
it was the lesson format.
He just doesn't
like having someone
else tell him what he
has to play and when.
So he doesn't like anyone
telling him what
he has to do ever.
So it turns out there's
plenty of ways you
can learn online by
yourself. There's jam play.
You pay like 100
and something bucks
and you get to choose
your instructor and choose
your lessons and you
can repeat them or fast
forward or whatever or
YouTube is another place
you can do that.
And he became a really,
really good guitar player and of
course I kept my hands
way off of that
because as soon as
my mom stink was on
any aspect of the guitar
playing, it was over for him.
The minute I messed
with his autonomy and
his control over this
learning guitar thing, done.
I was able to sort of
encourage him to you
know have you listened to
Eric Clapton yet? You
know, that kind of stuff.
And then what was
really interesting is
after he'd been playing
guitar for about a year and he
really was feeling confident,
he sheepishly came
to me and he said,
"You know, that list
serve we have in
town where people use stuff,
like if anyone had
a keyboard I might be
interested in learning piano."
And I was able to find
a keyboard on our list serve,
I paid like $100
for it and he taught
himself piano in the same way
he taught himself guitar.
And I really believe that he's
a better musician than
he ever would have been
if I had sat there and forced
him but that's
priorities in my house.
Same thing with athletics.
If you know, if your priority
is sports and you're
a very sports-oriented family
then you're quitting.
But then again my
other responses.
Childhood is supposed
to be a time when we
get to try lots of
different things.
In my house, you
know the kids can take
lessons in whatever they
want anytime my younger son
just took lessons in welding
a couple weekends ago and now
thinks he might want to try
hot and cold forging because
that could be
really interesting.
And luckily we have a place
nearby that will
teach them teens that.
But if you have a kid who's
14 who every moment there
is taken up with
playing soccer that
they'd been playing since
they were six and they really,
really hate it, what are
they not getting
an opportunity to try?
We tend to think that we'll be
raising quitters if we
let them quit but you
can't know if you like or don't
like something until
you have tried it.
So trying something
and then deciding
it's not for you
is not quitting.
That's knowing about yourself
and going on to something
else that might be more fun.
And often the answer
I'll get from parents is,
"But we have so much
invested in soccer."
And I just want to say,
"What's the return on this
investment you're hoping for?"
Like there's
a great New York Times
headline a while back that said,
"Your kid is not going to play
professional sports, now what?"
Know what your goals
are going into this and
that's one reason the sports
chapter was so fun to write.
There was one study
showing that,
it was a small,
an informal study but of
lots of kids where
this guy said,
"What's your favorite thing
about youth sports and what was
your least favorite thing
about youth sports?"
He asked serious
athletes about this.
And they said, "My least
favorite thing about
youth sports was
the ride home in the car
with my parents after games."
Now, I don't know
about you, a lot
of good talking
happens in the car
and the idea that that would be
the worst thing about
youth sports gives me headaches.
And their favorite thing
about youth sports was
when their grandparents
came to watch them play.
Because the grandparents
don't care what the score is.
The grandparents are in
it to watch the kid play.
One of my favorite
websites out there
about being a good
sports parent is called
Ilovetowatchyouplay.com
because that's
really in the end for
many kids what it's all about
and that's why I get
to spend a lot of
time on sports podcasts
and things like that.
Did you have a question?
>> Yeah. As someone who hasn't
read your book as of yet,
that might be one
of the answers.
>> Oh I should mention now, from
whatever not so reason
and I apologize there
aren't books here today,
that was a mistake on my part,
a misunderstanding but at
Amazon right now it's $4.52.
I can't get them
that cheaply so,
and you can only order four.
So like all of my friends
order books and bring
them to my house at $4.52,
so yeah st 4.52 at Amazon.
>> Yeah I can confirm
the pay back is,
I was about to buy two copies
because my question is,
as Elementary School kids,
and we have a science project
that was due today
and we have one parent me who
just kind of steps back
and watches the kid do
things and then
my wife just jumps in
and starts doing things but
then I'm also the one at
the end that exercises praises,
oh that's amazing, oh this
is going to be stellar,
you're so amazing, everything.
Instead of like what you
need to do with your kid,
what advice do you have for
parents with one another?
>> Okay, so, what this
really comes down to is
like there are
these big takeaways and on
the bookmark my son gave you
there are some takeaways.
One of the biggest
takeaways like
the fastest way to switch
your thinking right
now is to be thinking
long-term about what
you want for your kids.
So do you want
this science project
right here to be perfect
or do you want your kid
next year when the science
fair rolls around to not be
doing it the night before.
So real-life story Finnegan,
another authorized story.
Finnegan had
a science fair project
that he so half-asked,
it wasn't even half-asked,
it was like a sliver
asked and it was,
it came down to
a piece of trifold with
some sharpie big stars and
filling up space over here,
look over here,
that kind of thing.
And then he had to
go to the science
fair and sit there and
defend his project for
two hours next to
the girl who has the like
life-sized hologram of the uni-,
it's a scaled hologram
of the universe that she
totally did herself
of course not.
But that was an incredibly
important lesson.
Having to sit there in
front of something you
created or didn't
create and defend it,
is a really tough thing
to do but it's also
an incredible
learning experience
because the next time he had to
do a science project
and do you know which one
I'm talking about sweetie?
No, he's listening
to headphones.
Do you know which science
project I'm talking about that
was the killer
one the grays one?
>> That one.
>> The one with the alien?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, it was really, really
good. So I didn't even get
to see that project
until it was ready to
go to the science
fair and it was
so far beyond what
I thought my kid was
capable of simply
because he's like "Well,
I'm not doing what I did
last time and sitting
there and being humiliated
because that wasn't fun."
No, it wasn't fun, but it was
incredibly good
learning experience.
So, thinking long-term
instead of short-term,
my kid can do X today,
but where do I want them to be
in six months, in
a year, whatever?
You can even think in terms of,
my kids are going to go off
to college when they're 18,
what do I need them
to be able to do?
Make a checklist. There are
great checklists out there.
My friend, Julie Lythcott-Haims,
has a book called
"How to Raise an
Adult". She's got checklist.
I have checklists in the book,
age appropriate
checklist of what kids
are actually capable of doing,
that we don't ever ask them to
do because we're like, "Well,
of course, they can't do that,
that requires too
much whatever."
Long-term instead
of short-term is
the most important thing and
process instead of product.
I mean, if you come down
to the fact that the
doing for all good
projects at school,
really the doing of
the project should always be
far more important than
whatever the end product is,
it just so happens that kids
do like creating an end product.
So that's a great way to
sort of show something
off at the end.
Focus on process over product.
Focus on the parts that are
difficult for them saying,
"I'm really proud of you
for sticking with that
when I saw how hard
that was for you.
Long division maybe a
something that's
really hard for you.
And you know what,
I watched you do
your homework because you
thought I was just
cooking over here,
but I was peaking
every once in a while.
And I saw that number
three just gave you fits.
But you know what, you went
on to four and you
came back to three,
and I'm really proud
of you for that."
That's praising for effort,
that's constructive
praise for effort.
But that long-term
over short-term man,
that not only works for
our kids. It works for us.
It works for all kinds
of stuff because we tend
to parent in emergency mode.
This homework has to be perfect.
The kid doesn't
have lunch today.
Will she survive?
Yes, she will survive.
The fastest way
I tell schools if
they say, "This is
all well and good."
How do we send a message really,
really quickly to
the entire community that we
care more about the process
than the product,
that we care more about
the whole child than the grades?
I say, one of the great things
that schools have been
doing increasingly around
the country is making a rule,
that there's no
dropping forgotten
stuff off after first bell.
Not only is that sending
the message that what you
really care about is that
the kid learns to manage
their time and learns how to use
that plan book and can
cope with the consequences
of their actions,
but it's also fair if
you think about who can
afford to bring
stuff to school late,
it's certainly not people who do
shift work or rely on
public transportation.
So, from an equity
equality perspective,
it tends to be
a really great thing
for the school district.
So that's my
recommendation to schools,
is that rule works
wonders actually.
It's stepping away.
It's also what works when
other parents are going nuts,
and they're like,
"Can we do cello?
And we have all this tutoring,
and he's on the
traveling soccer league."
And you start to hyperventilate.
I wrote an article for
the Atlantic called "Why
Back-to-School Night Made
Me Feel Like a Bad Parent".
Step away, we are
each other's worst enemy
when it comes to that stuff.
So, step away. And
if you have to go,
I totally, totally get it.
Bibliography is at
jessicalahey.com.
If you sign up on my website,
there's a newsletter with
all the links to everything,
plus there's a new
book discussion group guide
that has questions
for each chapter
and stuff like that
and the bibliography and
all that fun stuff. Okay, sorry.
>> You talked about
expectations and consequences
and setting realistic things
for your children.
>> Yes.
>> What kind of consequences?
>> Is that kind of an extrinsic?
>> Yeah. So that's tough.
So, often consequences
tend to be extrinsic,
like punishment or I'm
going to take that thing
away from you.
Especially the take
that thing away from you,
we tend to say
we're going to take
those electronics away from you,
because in our adult brain,
that makes so much sense
because we're killing
two birds with one stone.
Not only will they be bummed out
and not want to lose
their electronics,
but if they lose
they will have more time to work
on their homework.
It's so brilliant.
Except for the fact
that for kids
whose frontal lobes aren't
fully cooked, it makes no sense.
It's like saying, "If you
can't build this treehouse,
I'm going to send you to Mars."
Because electronics, and
if you think about it,
normally what we're
saying is, "So
this is September or
April, August, September.
If in December your grade falls,
we're going to take
away your electronics."
And you have a kid, let's say,
middle school kid who's focused
on this homework assignment,
should I really put in my
all on this homework assignment?
They are very bad at saying
this homework assignment is
related to this thing
over here in
December that's totally
unrelated to school,
my electronics,
those two things don't equate,
so the closer you can
make consequences to
the actual consequences that
happen when a kid
doesn't do something.
So, for example, with homework,
the classic in our house
anyway would be,
if you don't get
your homework in to
the teacher and it
becomes a thing,
like it once always happens,
that's a process of learning,
then you will lead the
parent-teacher-kid conference,
where we talk about how
we can best help you,
where we can talk
about strategy.
We're not going to lead that,
you are, because you're the
one who's forgetting
your homework.
So you have to set that meeting
up and you have
to make it happen.
You can work behind
the scenes to kind
of pull some strings.
So you can email
the teacher and say,
"My kid's going
to come up to you
today and ask you to
make an appointment.
And if that doesn't happen,
could you let me know
or could you sort of
engineer a moment
where it might be
easier for the kid to ask that?"
I do that as a teacher
all the time.
Parents will get in
touch with me and say,
"She really needs to talk to
you about something
she's upset about.
And I have a feeling
she's not going to.
So, could you kind of make
an opportune moment for that?
That's really helpful for us."
By the way, those of you who
help your kids with homework,
homework is information for us.
So, a classic in Math class,
a friend of mine talks
about this all the time,
that she'll have in Algebra one,
she'll get homework back that
uses trigonometry to
figure something out,
and she'll ask
the kids, "So, how
did you arrive at this answer?"
And the kids are
like, "I don't know,
ask my dad. I don't know."
And it's pretty clear
that the kid hasn't
been doing the work,
and whatever, except
for the fact that
now the teacher can't tell
what the kid can and can't do.
So, the more opportunities
for information, the better.
So, consequences really should,
as best you can,
make them flow from whatever
it was the kid didn't do.
A friend of mine, at
the end of the book,
inevitably someone
asked the question of,
"Well, what about real failure
like failing out
of school failure?"
There's a story at the end
of the book about that.
Someone whose son was failing
out of school because he
refused to sort of take
command of the
situation and work.
She and I talked about getting
a probationary semester
for her son.
She negotiated this probationary
semester before
they kicked him out,
and we got really lucky there.
But then, she had
to say to her son,
"You have this
probationary semester.
So you're going to
go for a couple days
to this other school,
which is where
you'll have to go to
school if you flunk
out of this school."
And it was not
a great choice for him.
It was not a really great school
for him to go to.
And he attended
that other school for the day.
And he came home,
and he's like, "Okay,
I'm in, what do I have to do?"
And she said, "Well, you
should also know that I'm not
going to be completing
stuff for you anymore.
This is you, this
is your education,
this is your decision,
we need buy-in from you."
He still talks
about that moment,
the kid I kept in touch
with the parent and the kid,
as being the turning
point in his life.
And I get to report this
because she just
found out recently,
he's going to college
now on full scholarship.
He not only took control
of his education,
completely turned it around.
And by the way, when a kid
turns around education,
that's when we get to write
the really good letters
of recommendation.
The kids who have just been
sort of coasting or kids who
just sort of had been
perfect all along,
those letters are whatever,
they're fun, fine.
But the letters of kids
who really have sort
of taken that
opportunity to change,
who get inspired and
decide to change things,
those are the letters that
get them into college.
And that's what
happened with this kid.
He had more scholarships to
choose from than he
knew what to do with.
And so, he's going
to college for
free, his dream college.
And really because
he nearly failed out,
so he has a story to tell
about his transcript.
He was able to say, "Look,
you look at my transcript,
and you think I really was
falling apart freshman year,
let me tell you that story.
And let me tell you where I am
now as a human being
because of that story."
He had to suffer
the real consequences.
And if he had failed
out of school,
I know for a fact
his mother would
have taken him and put
him in that other school,
and he would have had
to sink or swim there.
It ended up being
a fantastic opportunity
for him and maybe
even opportunity for
him to realize that wasn't what
he wanted and find
out if there would
be a way that he could work
his way back into
the other school.
That's always a possibility too.
Yes. Behind you.
Yeah, yeah, sorry.
I have a room by
the way till 1:30
but I'm happy to stick
around and answer questions,
as long as I'm not
going anywhere.
>> Okay. I totally understand as
parents not wanting to be
controlled and corrected.
I happened to have my oldest
going to sixth grader.
And he just really
doesn't want to work hard
when it comes to school work.
>> Right.
>> He's very bright.
If that means he cannot
work hard on this assignment
or not study much
for this test and
he gets a B, he
is fine with that.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm not fine with that.
>> Right.
>> Because I know he put
zero effort into that B, right?
>> Right.
>> And this is
a constant argument with us,
and it's also, so what
do you do with that kid.
>> Okay, so number
one if you want
a really thorough 15
minute long answer,
it's at the gift of
failure facts to how to
motivate kids who coast.
>> Okay.
>> What you also
need to know from
a developmental
perspective is this.
Until you get to middle school
like sixth grade, seventh grade,
eighth grade, really
the end of fifth grade,
kids are really
focused internally.
And they're really focused
on getting your love
and approval.
They're really
focused on how you're
reacting to what they're doing.
Fifth grade, sixth grade,
seventh grade,
suddenly the world opens up.
The social life opens up and
hormones start to kick in,
and oh my gosh people
are looking at me,
and oh my gosh for,
the big joke in middle school
is that all middle schoolers
believed that everyone is
looking at them all the time,
which means that they have
to be focused on themselves,
and everyone is so
focused on themselves,
they are not actually
looking at each other.
So, they're now more
outwardly focused.
And friendships tend to become
more outwardly focused,
and so they become,
that takes front seat
for a little while and
understanding that
is going to go
a long way towards helping
you understand the motivation.
At least understanding why
your kid maybe pulling back
from the school stuff
which maybe the year before
he was all over that.
So, understanding
motivation is really,
really important because
that helps you understand
where your fulcrum point is.
Where those levers
can get installed,
and knowing what their goals
are is going to be
really important. You
can talk to your kid.
If you happen to know
that your kid wants
to get into a certain
Math class the next year,
or your kid wants to go
to a certain college,
or your kid wants to do
a certain thing for work,
one of the things
like kid says I really
want to be an architect,
I don't know whatever.
You can talk to them
about the fact that well,
how do you plan to get there?
One of the things I
do a lot as an adviser
to kids is not
just talk about what were
their long-term goals are,
because well that's
all well and good.
Talking to them about the goals,
the short-term achievable
goals they have
to get through to get to
those long-term goals,
that's called self-directed
executive function,
when they can come up with
those intermediary steps
to get to the big
goal out there.
It can be less
threatening to talk about
these short-term goals than
that big one out there,
and it's also more about
process than product.
So if you happen to know
that your kid really wants to
play soccer but you have to have
a C or better to play soccer,
then there's your fulcrum point.
If you happen to know
that your kid wants to
go to this high school
as opposed to that one,
but this high school is a
little bit harder to get into,
then you can know well,
that's your fulcrum point.
If you really want to
be over there let's talk
about your strategies for
how to make that happen.
For kids who are coasting,
honestly, the reaction they're
giving out of you for not,
sometimes for not putting
in that extra little bit,
it can also be, remember
when I talked about kids not
wanting to fail and that's
really scary for them.
If you're telling
them constantly,
look, we know you're not
working up to your potential,
we know you're
smarter than this,
in the back of the head
one of the things
that kids can hear is,
but what if I'm not.
And so going that extra step
can be really scary
because what if I'm
not as smart as
other people think I am?
What if my friends find out?
What if my teachers find out?
So focusing more on the process
rather than that end
product can sort of
help them get over that.
The other thing that can help,
when I go to talk to kids,
you can- I talk to them
about I look at
the audience and I say,
if you're coasting and
you know who you are
you are not becoming smarter
as fast as your classmates,
because what we know
about the brain is,
if you read Carol
Dweck's "Mindset",
what we know is
that the harder we
push ourselves and this
goes for adults too.
The more we push
ourselves outside of
our comfort zone like
if I were to take,
I don't know ballroom
dancing which would
be a nightmare scenario for me,
because I just, I'm clumsy.
But I would be making
connections in my brain.
I would become less clumsy.
If I am not great at
Math but I push
myself harder in Math,
I'm learning more because I'm
making more connections
in our brain,
that sort of the backwards
when we tell older people
to do crossword puzzles so that
they don't lose
those connections with kids,
the more connections
they make the
smarter they will become,
because that's how
our brains work.
We're not born with
an IQ number and God
forbid if you have
to get your kid an IQ test
for some reason,
and I actually post
it that there's
no really good reason
to do that,
the IQ test was never
intended to be a measure
of a numerical measure
of intelligence.
There's a fantastic book by
Scott Barry Kaufman
called "Ungifted ",
where he talks about
the history of the IQ test.
He tells this story
through the lens of
a person who was
Special Ed and now has PhD,
and he works basically on
the neuroscience of creativity,
and the psychology
of creativity,
and what intelligence and
creativity have to
do with one another.
For example, someone with
dyslexia may score
lower on an IQ test,
but how many people in
this room know there's
an upside to dyslexia?
That there are things people
with dyslexia can do that
people without dyslexia can't
or at least not as well?
Yeah. Some of the most
amazing astronomers
we've had in the history
of humankind have been
dyslexic because they have
the ability to see
sort of relationships
between things and
distance and time in
a way that people who
are non-dyslexic don't.
There's a great book called,
"The Upside of Dyslexia."
By the way that's
all about that.
Most IQ tests don't-
Most intelligence tests
don't take things like
creativity into account or
your individual quirks
about how you think.
And so Scott Barry Kaufman is
currently working to
try to come up with
a measure of intelligence
that encompasses things
like being a people person,
being creative person,
thinking in a way
that's different from
your peers think.
So putting as much focus
on things like that,
and understanding where
this is coming from,
and also understanding
that your kid
really truly believes because
we tend to talk good game.
Does your kid really truly
believe that what you care about
is learning or is it
just a lot of this?
Because if they see
us freaking out over
a low grade or going all
effusive and crazy
over a high grade,
but what we're saying is,
oh it's really it's for
learning I care about,
they're more apt to follow sort
of they know that what
we really mean is this.
Oh, I had a mother
recently ask me,
my kids, they just
won't read for fun.
My son will not read for fun.
Number one, could you
give me a list of really
challenging books that he
will want to read for fun?
Could you do that for me?
And I was like, that's like
a magic list that
if you could come up
with that would be great.
And I said, well I have
to start here first,
do your children
see you read for
fun? And the answer is no.
She had to admit that she was,
I'm so busy ba ba ba blah,
and when she did read she
read on a tablet and her kids
didn't know what she
was doing on the tablet.
It wasn't clear that
she was reading.
So if you're not
reading I don't really
know how I'm supposed to
help you make it clear to
your children that
you think it's
an important thing to do.
Then and I said, okay,
well let's get back
to this magic list.
What do your kids like to read?
And she said, well
they really like,
this one really
likes those Diary
of a Wimpy Kid books but I threw
those away because
they're stupid. I know.
For the record, when
it comes to literacy,
the ideal mix of
challenge levels
is 30 percent comfortably
below your reading level,
30 percent at
your reading level,
I should say a
third, a third and a
third above your reading level.
This is about acquiring
new vocabulary.
This is about strengthening it.
This is about
comfort and fluency.
This is about feeling
confident, competent feeling.
It's the reason why
I go back and read
things like "Little Women"
or "Pride and Prejudice".
It's the reason kids love
repetitive shows because
they take like "Blues Clues"
always happens the same.
I mean, it drives us crazy
but for them it makes them so,
it makes them feel
like they have mastery,
because they know
what's coming next,
and they can predict what
the answer is going to be,
and that makes them
feel like they're smart,
it makes them feel
like they're competent,
like they're powerful.
And that's what
reading stuff that's
below their reading level does.
If your kid is in
high school and every once
in a while likes to go back
to those copies of
whatever that they
read in fifth grade,
that's great.
That is a really productive use
of their time, not,
you know sweetie, I know
you're better than those books.
What you're saying
to them is I think,
not just that I think
what you love is
stupid but I think
you're stupid.
These choices you're
making are stupid thereby,
I don't think as much of you.
So there's like
16 different things all in
one answer, but honestly,
focusing more on those sort
of the long-term, the goals,
the levers, making sure
your kid knows you're
interested in him, her.
Making sure your kid
knows that you
really do care
about the learning,
which means if
you're modeling that,
you're going to have
to put yourself now,
and like try things that
are uncomfortable for you.
They're going to have to
see you trying some things
that push you a little bit
beyond your ability level.
Because we can say
that all we want,
but until they see us take
intellectual and
emotional risks,
they don't really
believe that that's
something worth doing for them.
That's why it's so
important for teachers to
admit when they don't
know the answers,
and to say, you know what,
I don't know, let me
look that up for you.
Thank you so so much
for being here today.
I really appreciate
it so much and I'm
going to stick around and answer
questions if anyone has more.
If you didn't get
a book marker or
a card or you want to...
If you want to get
in touch with me,
the contact form at my website,
it's just my email,
go straight to my email box
and I'll be ha...
And for those of you who
want a spouse to sort
of hear some of this,
because that's a question
I get a lot too,
I will be speaking
on Mercer Island
tomorrow night at
the Mercer Island High School
and it's open to the public.
Unfortunately, the talk
I'm giving tonight is not,
but the one on Mercer Island
tomorrow is open to the public,
and everyone is welcome.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you very very much.
Thank you.